you do seem calmer to me we were
chatting a little bit when you got here
seems like you've calmed down i know you
had your second child recently
fatherhood calming me down um
fatherhood made me have to figure myself
out
because i didn't want my kids to go
through you know
some of the stuff that i went through
not saying it was all bad but some of
the stuff that i went through so
um i just kept trying and failing with
the temper
and i ended up taking mushrooms
you took mushrooms to help you with your
temper no i was
no i didn't do that it inadvertently
helped me i just took it because i was
like all right i'm gonna be 53
i've never tripped like am i gonna miss
out on that i'll do it once
i'm in the desert that's what you're
supposed to do right so i did it
and you know i didn't do a lot of it so
i i sort of mini trip you know what i
mean like the tv looked like it was
gonna you know get bigger and fall on me
right sink looked like it was breathing
or whatever right um
but then after that i was sort of left
with this
uh profound sense of loneliness and not
feeling loved
right so i'm literally laying there
going what the hell is this i love my
wife and i love my kids and i figured it
out i go oh this is how i felt growing
up
i get it and then i i was like i need
i've been running from this this feeling
that's why hey
i do stand up i fly helicopters am i
cool do you like me
and i i just like the pandemic really
just not having anything to do
right just slowed everything down and
then all of that smoke
just kind of came back and i was trying
just you know organizing my office
and i couldn't stay in front of it so i
was kind of like all right i need to sit
and figure out what this
is so it's kind of funny i ran from it
for 30 years
and in three months i kind of figured it
all out
put like all the pieces together so um
it's funny now i haven't like flipped
out or yelled in my house
and uh but now i'm going up i still have
that need to be liked so now i'm like
going up to my wife like you know i
haven't yelled in a while
have you noticed yeah am i a swell guy
do you like me so i still have that
crushing need to be liked but
uh i'm not like flipping out yeah i feel
great i feel like
light and all of that and uh that's nice
and i'm not worried about the whole
oh if you get happy you're not going to
be funny it's like no maybe i could have
a new
like empathetic you know way of going at
[ __ ] while still you know i will still
forever rip apart inconsiderate
people who i deem in my own dictator
world
as inconsiderate people right right i
had a murderous thought in target
with this [ __ ] self-involved woman
who's just
shooting this [ __ ] with like the person
that's registered the six people behind
you
just do the transaction and get out of
there
and like all the stories were
self-serving and about herself
and i just felt it yeah i just felt it
coming up you know we got a tropical
storm developing you know just
so you feel even though you're
enlightened now and you've found
peace i'm so enlightened i'm not i i've
figured out that i
i why i'm [ __ ] up but i'm not
enlightened okay i'm still a [ __ ]
don't you dare compliment me conan okay
take you over in that chair
you